NEEDED TO BE. ROB AND I DON'T
KNOW REALLY. GOOD AFTERNOON
WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
FIRST MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE N. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT IS MARCH
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE LET
ME FIRST START BY THANKING ALL
THE STAFF WHO HAVE MADE A
RETURN TO THE CAPITOL TO HEAR
BILLS POSSIBLE OIL SO. WE WANT
TO THANK BACK ARA. OR COMMITTEE
SECRETARY WHO'S NOT SEEN IN
PERSON IN A YEAR JUST GOOD TO
HAVE YOU BACK BOB DO TO COVERT
NINETEEN SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AT THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL
SO ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THE MASS BE
WARM. AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CORE TESTIFYING
WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
A VIDEO CONFERENCE SITE IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE TO YOU IT IS THE
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF THE
HOUSE THE MEMBERS BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED IN FOR HEARING THAT
INCLUDES WEARING A MASK. WE
HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY ARE
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF MEMBERS A MINIMUM
CONTINUE TO STAFF AND A LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
MEDIA TO MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACE. THERE ARE ALSO STRICT
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER THE CAPITAL R.
IF YOU ARE IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM IF YOU WANT TO
TESTIFY THE BILL JUST RAISE
YOUR HAND UNLESS YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME PLEASE DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE AND WE ASK
YOU TO EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE
ALSO BE SURE TO OBSERVE FISCAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE ALSO HAVE
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOMS AT
THE CAPITOL CURRENTLY ON THE
FIRST FLOOR STATE CAPITOLROOM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE. FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK QUESTIONS. OF THOSE
WITNESSES. WE ALSO ALLOWED US
TO DIAL IN THROUGH A TELEPHONE
SERVICE THE CALL NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN FORTY TWO OH
TWO AGAIN ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TWO. THESE NUMBERS
WILL BE ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TELEVISION SCREEN IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE CALLING ON PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST A BILL YOU'LL REMAIN ON
THE LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AT.
916-319-2085 AGAIN 916-319-2085
MY STAFF CAN HELP AND I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON OUR- HOUSING
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. WE MAY NEED
TO LIMIT HOW LONG THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN AS ROMA TAKE
HEARING SCHEDULE I JUST ONE
AGAIN THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND UNDERSTANDING SO
WITH THAT- ONE WE START BY
CALLING THE WORLD MADAM
SECRETARY. CHIU HERE WE ARE
STILL HERE GABRIELLE YEAH KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN MARK SILVA.
WICKS YOUR AND I'LL JUST TAKE A
MOMENT AND WELCOME SOME OF THE
NEWER MEMBERS TO OUR COMMITTEE
INCLUDING OUR VICE CHAIR
WELCOME ONE WELCOME- IS WICKS
AND I THINK WALK ME BACK MISTER
KALRA IF I RECALL WELCOME BACK
IN ADDITION ALL OF OUR OTHER
PREVIOUS MEMBERS- LET ME ALSO
NOW AT THIS MOMENT ASK FOR
MOTION TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULE SINCE OUR FIRST MEETING AS
MOTION BY MISTER WICKS SECOND
BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUICK SILVA
MADAM SECRETARY. YOU HI. THEY
ARE TOO HIGH HI GABRIELLE
CAMBIADO KALRA. HELLO I KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN CORK
SILVA. HI MARK SILVA I WICKS
WICKS HI THE ADOPT THE ARTS
COMMITTEE RULES RE ADOPTED AND
WE DO HAVE TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT
ITEM TO WHICH IS AB THREE FOUR
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND AB FIVE BUT SORRY
FILE IN FIVE A. B. FORTY TWO
BOB ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD COULD
I HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT AGENDA. IS
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY. FORTY FIVE. TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY AND CAN
MEET ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND- AB FORTY TO DO
PASSES THAT ENDED. R. Q. HI IF
YOU BY THE ARCO ART ART BY
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA. CLOSE
I KILEY. HIGHLY I MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA ROXY VI<c.cyan> WEEKS</c>
WEEK FIVE THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE
PASSED FROM WE HAVE FOUR BILLS
TO HEAR TODAY I BELIEVE TWO OF
THEM ARE GOING TO BE. PRESENTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN HER
OWN ITEM FILE ITEM THREE A. B.
FOUR ONE ONE. AND FILE ITEM FOR
AB FOUR THIRTEEN BY TEN AND
WITH THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN. IF YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT
A BEFORE ELEVEN THE- DICES
YOURS- THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL IT REMAINS AN
IMPORTANT ONE ADDRESSING A
PERSISTENT PROBLEM AB FOUR ONE
ONE WHAT AN ACTIVE VETERANS
HOUSING AND HOMELESS PREVENTION
BOND ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO AUTHORIZE THE ISSUANCE OF
BONDS. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
WITH SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
VETERANS UNDER THE EXISTING
PHP- PROGRAM IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
CALIFORNIA'S APPROVED PROP
FORTY ONE- THE V. HHP BOND WITH
AN INITIAL SIX HUNDRED MILLION
TO THE FUN BALL TYPE FAMILY
HOUSING FOR VETERANS CREATING
HHP OVER FIVE ROUNDS OF FUNDING-
THIS BOND HAS CREATED NEARLY A-
TWENTY SIX. HOUR A TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS FOR VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THERE IS NOW
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION. OF
REMAINING AT A RATE OF SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION PER ROUND THE
FUNDING WILL RUN OUT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. TO CONTINUE FUNDING
THE PROGRAM WITHOUT A BREAK WE
NEED TO PLACE A BOND ON THE
BALLOT- THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED
ELEVEN THOUSAND HOMELESS
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
EVEN MORE EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSECURITY OR STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. IN TRANSITION
THE NUMBER HAS BEEN REDUCED-
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS. EIGHTY FOUR ONE ONE
WILL ASSIST VETERANS WHO ARE
HOMELESS OR WHO NEED AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING- SECURE HOUSING
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR ONE I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS TESTIFYING
TODAY ARE GREAT CASE. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE CONNECT US TO
THE FIRST WITNESS. I DO NOT
SHOW THAT GREG HAYES HAS JOINED
THE CALL YET. HOWEVER IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE. OUR OUTDOORS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES ON
BEHALF OF- MISTER HAYES IF IT'S
ALL RIGHT- I CANNOT PRESENT IN
HIS STEAD PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN ALEX TOWARDS A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES-
WE ARE CONSORTIUMS SEVEN
NONPROFIT VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES PROVIDE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO MORE THAN. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA VETERANS
HOW THE OVER FOUR THOUSAND JOB
TRAINING AND PLACEMENT TO
ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND
VETERANS. NEARLY NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEALS TO VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- THIS
MEASURE IN ITS- PREVIOUS
ITERATION WAS A PRIORITY
MEASURE FOR THE CAVS AGENCIES
AND I WANT TO EXPRESS. OUR
THANKS TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN I WENT
FOR THIS FOLLOW UP AFTERWARDS-
IN OUR SOON TO BE RELEASED
TWENTY TWENTY STATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS COMMUNITY
REPORT WE FOUND THAT THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BOTH IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND- AMONGST
THE VETERAN POPULATION. IS
INCREASING AND OBVIOUSLY
CONCERNING TREND FOR CALIFORNIA
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR OUR VETERAN
POPULATION. AND DESPITE-
PROGRESS MADE IN THE STATE OF
SUPPORT IN THE HOUSE HOMELESS
VETERANS THE DATA TRENDS SHOW
THAT- THAT MORRIS NEED MORE
ACTION IS NEEDED- THE BOTTOM
THIRTY TO FIND- THE FIGHTERS
HOMELESSNESS- HOPE HOUSING AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION PROGRAMS
WILL SOON BE EXHAUSTED AS
YOU'RE AWARE. OF THE- TWO
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS- PRODUCE
FOR VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE PROJECT- NEARBY
IN THE REGION- CAP THE MEMBRANE
THE NATION'S FINEST PARTNERED
WITH THE CITY OF RANCHO CORDOVA
AND MERCY HOUSING TO BUILD. ONE
HUNDRED UNITS OF A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SIXTY UNITS
OF TRANSITIONAL HOW THE ON THE
OLD. METER FOR STATE- USING
THIS BE A CHANGE PEOPLE NEED-
THIS IS THE FIRST PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BUILT IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION FOR HOMELESS
VETERANS WITH DISABILITIES-
AMENITIES INCLUDE A COMMUNITY
ROOM WITH KITCHEN AND LOUNGE
AREA ONSITE PARKING LAUNDRY
FACILITIES IN THE COMPUTER LAB
IN THE SPECTRUM OF. SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED AT THE
VILLAGE INCLUDING COUNSELING
JOB TRAINING MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
AND GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL
THERAPY I HIGHLIGHT THAT
PROJECT IN A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
JUST ONE OF MANY PROJECTS THAT.
THE BJP. PROGRAMS HELP FUNDED
SO FOR THE REASONS CABS ON A
PARTNERS. VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE ONE AGAIN-
THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
LEADERS ON THIS. AND- URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU MUCH. OKAY
SOME. OUR THOSE ARE THE ONLY A
WITH WE HAVE ON FILE AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO. WITNESS ON
FILE SO IF I CAN'T TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED IF YOU COULD
ACKNOWLEDGE IF THERE ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THEY WISH
TO. TESTIFY EITHER IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. YEAH AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN LONDON FERAL. ONLY YOU
HAVE TO AND MAKE YOU WILL GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE BY
HAD. FINE ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MAXIMO CAROLINE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CODY I
WORK WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR USE I AM A USE MYSELF- I AM
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD
PREVENT AND REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG CURRENT AND FORMER
PROSECUTOR. RIGHT CRITICAL
HOUSING SUPPORT RESOURCES
DURING COVET THANK YOU. AND SO
WE DO HAVE A PMR JOINING THE
QUEUE WILL NEXT MOVE TO LINE
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MARK FAVORS
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG SUPPORT
MAYBE FOR ELEVEN TO CONTINUE
SURPRISE- PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO HELP OUR VETERANS INCLUDING
ALMOST SPECIMENS. WE HAVE
SUGGESTED TO THE AUTHOR THAT WE
STREAMLINED THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE PROGRAM BY ADMINISTERING
THE FUND TO THE SET ASIDE FOR
VETERANS THROUGH THE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN MAXIMO
CAROLINA ONE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ROSHAN OF HARASSING. SYSTEM I
MEAN YOU HAVE TO GET WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS TRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOUR ONE THREE WHICH
WOULD PREVENT AND REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AMONG CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND THE-
YOU SUPPORT RESOURCES DURING
COVERED. A LARGE AMOUNT OF%
EUTHANASIA FOSTER CARE TRAIN
COMMENCEMENT AND ONCE WE WILL
HOUSING. AND PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS ARE LESS LIKELY TO
SAINT LUCIA SCHOOLS HAVE ACCESS
RENTAL HOUSING TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT. AND MAINTAIN
FRIENDSHIPS. THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ABUSE VIOLENCE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
IT SHOULD BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS PROGRESSION AND
COMPLETING A KID RATHER THAN
BEING FACED WITH HOMELESSNESS
AND UNSTABLE HOUSING. GIVING
ARE YOU STRUCTURE WHEN THEY
NEED IT MOST WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
CHANGE THEIR LIVES FOR THE
BETTER. HOW CAN CONSCIOUSLY
ALLOW ARGUES OUR CHILDREN TO BE
LEFT ALONE TO FACE THE BURDEN
OF HOMELESSNESS. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT INCLUDING
USE. BUT IT'S NOT WAITING
LONGER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
PROMISES THAT THE POTS YOU CAN.
OUR COUNTRY ARE FACING THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE ONE MORE LOCAL
TRYING ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
TORRANCE AND I'M A HUGE
ADVOCATE WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU. I VERY
EXPENSIVE PART FOR AB FOUR ONE
THREE WHICH COULD WHICH WOULD
PREVENT AND REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS
YOU. I'D CRITICAL HOUSING
SUPPORT. THANK OF IT. STOP
BEING HOMELESS AND I'VE BEEN
HOMELESS AND IT WAS NOT FUN-
I'M HOPING WITH THIS BILL WE
HAVE ACCESS. TO HOUSING SO THAT
ONE MEMBER AND CURRENT BAR SHE
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT STOP BY WELL AND
SO. THEY CAN HAVE THE ABILITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE MORE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE FORTY ONE THESE
BY HAD. HI I'M SORRY I JUST
HEARD TESTIMONY I MEAN- SUPPORT
FOR FOUR ONE ONE AND FOUR ONE
THREE IS THIS FOR FOUR ONE ONE.
THIS IS FOR FOUR ONE ONE AB AND
WANTED EVERYONE. OKAY ARE A
GREAT SUPPORT FOR WONDERING
THAT WHEN I SAY I'M SORRY FOR
WHAT YOU'RE TIME. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO
MAKE YOU. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE ROPES OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THE ONE COMMENT. I JUST WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK AND
RECOGNIZE THE AUTHOR FOR HER
TREMENDOUS CHAMPION OF THIS
ISSUE OVER THE MANY YEARS. WE
ALL KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY
FOLKS WHO ARE LEFT OUT. IN THIS
HOUSING CRISIS BUT THAT
INCLUDES IN PARTICULAR HER
VETERANS. AND THERE ARE MANY
CITIES AROUND THE STATE- THAT
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO ELIMINATE VETERAN
HOMELESSNESS BUT WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES. AT LAST BOND MEASURE
ADDED THOUSANDS OF UNITS BUT-
WE STILL NEED MORE SO JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ALSO
WANTED JUST. THE KNOWLEDGE
ANOTHER STILL ONGOING
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER.
THERE'S A WAY TO BETTER
STREAMLINE SOME THESE FUNDING
PROGRAMS WHICH I KNOW YOU'RE
ENGAGE IN AND- LOOK FOR TO SEE
WHERE THAT GOES BUT- GIVEN THAT
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS AND-
I KNOW. HOW MY STAFF REQUESTED
IF- IF IT PLEASES THE AUTHOR
HAPPEN BE ADDED AS A JOINT
AUTHORS TO THIS BILL I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING. WE NEED TO
PUSH ON AND- HOPEFULLY GET DONE
THIS YEAR. MY SACRAMENTO. WE
HAVE YOU ON AS A JOINT AUTHORS
REALLY APPRECIATE- CHRIS PART
ON THIS HAPPY TO. HAPPY TO.
MISS WORKS. ALSO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BE OUT ON CO AUTHOR.
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU. BRITAIN'S PROMOTION WITH
THE BILLS ARE SECOND. THERE'S
BEEN A SECOND ANY FURTHER
CONVERSATION. TO THE AUTHOR ANY
FINAL COMMENTS SUCH AS TO- TO
CLOSE IT WE HAVE SEEN JUST AN
EXPLOSION AND- THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE ONE AREA
WHERE YOU'VE SEEN A LOT OF
IMPROVEMENTS IT IS AND-
VETERANS THING AND- I THINK WE
CAN REALLY THANK THE INVESTMENT
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
THE HHP HAS DONE A TREMENDOUS
SERVICE TO OUR VETERANS-
ESPECIALLY WITH THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES AND FOR A LOT OF THE
VETERANS. JUST HOUSING IS NOT
ENOUGH SO- FIVE WE WANT TO GET
THIS ON THE BALLOT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WITH A MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY
FOUR ELEVEN OUR MOTION TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
MILITARY AND VETERANS OF
VETERAN AFFAIRS CHIU HI TWO
FIVE THEY ARE TOO HIGH YEAH BY
GABRIEL. KALRA RIGHT KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY I MAIENSCHEIN
QUIKSILVER. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
WEEKS FIVE WEEKS FIVE. FIFTY
FOUR FIVE SIX TWO ZERO SAN YOUR
MEASURE HAS THE VOTES TO GET IT
WILL WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON I UNDERSTAND YOU CAN
ALSO BE PRESENTING THE NEXT
ITEM YOU'RE HAPPY PERCENT ALL
THE ITEMS OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY IF YOU LIKE. FILE ITEM
FOR AB FOUR THIRTEEN TEAM YES
AND YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD SOME
COMMENTS FROM US SUPPORTERS
ABOUT WHAT A GREAT MESSAGES-
SOME YOU HAVE MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. AND IT'S A
BILL THAT HELPS ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AMONG CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER USE AUTHORED
FOSTER YOUTH-
DISPROPORTIONATELY FACE A
HIGHER LEVELS OF HOMELESSNESS
AND THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS IT
IS TO PREVENT THEM FROM LOSING
HOUSING IN THE FIRST PLACE
ACCORDING TO AGE JULY TWENTY
TWENTY SURVEY THE MAJORITY OF
YOU FOR WHICH WERE WORKING WHEN
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN HAVE EITHER
LOST THEIR JOBS OR HAD A
REDUCTION IN HOURS. WITHIN THE
CURRENT TO FOSTER YOUTH
POPULATION IT WAS 79% AND FOR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH 60%
ADDITIONALLY THREE QUARTERS OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE NO
HOUSING EDUCATION SERVICES TO A
FOSTER YOUTH AS THEY TRANSITION
OUT OF YEAH. OVER NINETEEN AS
ONLY EXASPERATED THIS HOUSING
INSTABILITY SINCE FOSTER YOU
MAY NOT HAVE THE SAME EMOTIONAL
AND ECONOMIC SUPPORT SYSTEM
THAT OTHER YOUNG ADULTS HAVE
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES TRAINING
FOR CHILD WELFARE WORKERS AND
PROBATION OFFICERS ON HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE AND
PROVIDES PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
PROGRAMS THAT CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AMONG
FOSTER YOUTH. THE AUTHOR. HAS-
I ME TO A TO BOTH OF THE ABOUT.
ON PAID FIVE OF THE- HE'S
WORKED WITH THE AND COME UP THE
AGREE THE ONLY THE FIRST
PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO COUNTIES
WITH ALLOCATION OF. TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE. AND I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES- WITH ME
TODAY ON THE PHONE. YEAH AND-
I'M SURE THEY WOULD LIKE TO.
SAY SOMETHING. THANK YOU- TO
THE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OUR TWO WITNESSES- SIMONE
DIRECTLY- THE DIRECTOR OF
HOUSING AND HEALTH OF THE JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR USED AS
WELL AS- I JOHNNY DUNLAP. WHOSE
YOUTH ADVOCATE ALSO WITH THE
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
SURE AND OFF AIRLINE THERE OPEN
MON AND IM JUNI. THANK YOU HI
THIS IS DIMOND CORRECTLY I
THINK ALL ARMS SPEAK AND THEN
ASIA NIKOLE COE ARE DIRECTLY
AFTER ME I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN CHIU AND MEMBERS OF
THE CANADIAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
LOOKING AT TAKING GREAT STRIDES
TO ADDRESS THE ALARMING RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS. I FOSTER USE- AND
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT YOU HAVE
BETTER OUTCOMES ON ALL FRONTS-
THE WHEN THEY CHOOSE TO STAND
IN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE BIRTH
OPT OUT. HOWEVER THERE'S STILL
WORK TO DO NEARLY ONE IN FIVE
USE THAT EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS WHILE IN FOSTER
CARE BETWEEN H. NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE AND ONE IN COURT. COME WITH
THAT AFTER TRANSITIONING OUT OF
CARE. BETWEEN TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY THREE. DURING THE COLD
NINETEEN. MAINTAINING HOUSING
FACILITY AS AS WE ALL KNOW IS
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT- FOR
CURRENT FORM OF DR UNIT. EIGHT
MEN DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY JOB LOSS AND OFTEN LACK THE
SUPPORT OF AN EXTENDED FAMILY
THAT MANY YOUNG ADULTS WHO ARE
RELYING ON AND THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW. I USED TO
ACQUIRE JUST SIMPLISTIC HEARING
IN MAINTAINING HELPING A
CUSTOMER DRIVEN PROBATION
OFFICERS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
TRAINED ON HOW TO ASSIST THEM
WITH THAT. AND AS YOU HEARD 72%
OF COUNTY DO NOT HAVE HOUSING
NAVIGATION AVAILABLE TO YOU.
ONCE YOU LEAVE CARE WE LACK
ADEQUATE RESOURCES DEMAND.
STATEWIDE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE YOU ARE ON A WAITING LIST
FOR EXCUSE PEOPLE CLASS. I
THINK THE PORT OF TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. AND DEMANDED
GREATEST MISTAKE HIGH COST
COUNTIES WHERE THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT BY AFFECTED
PROGRAM WHICH SERVES OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED USE THAT ANY
GIVEN NIGHT ALONG WITH OVER
THREE HUNDRED UP THEIR
CHILDREN. AB THIRTEEN FOR
THIRTEEN WOULD ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS BY BUILDING ON WHAT WE
KNOW WORK. THE BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH HOUSING NAVIGATION
CAPACITY IN CHILD WELFARE BY
ADDING HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE THE TRAINING TOPICS
FOR CHILD WELFARE WORKERS AND
PROBATION OFFICER. AND MAKING A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR HOUSING
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM A PERMANENT
PROGRAM. EIGHTY FOUR THIRTEEN
WOULD RETAIN FUNDING FOR
SUPPORTIVE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
BY REMOVING SUSPENSION OF EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM. AND
ESTABLISHING A HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT FOR THE JEWISH
PEOPLE HER GRAMMY. COUNTIES
WITH THE HIGHEST RENTAL CAR. IT
HAS BEEN. OF THE YOU THE CAN.
AND TO GET THE PROVISION WHAT
HOW CURRENT FORM ACROSS TO YOU
A CHEAP HOW FACILITY AND PER
AND REDUCE. THAT CRITICAL PAGE
LIFE. I'LL BE URGING TO VOTE I
IT PARTNER. THANK SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOOKS. LIKE
GO AHEAD YEAH GOOD ACTORS CHAIR
MEN OF THE MY NAME ASIAN EXAM
MY FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR JOHN ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH I AM ALSO A JUNIOR FACT
MINISTER. AND IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE I'VE BEEN IN
GUARDIANSHIPS ACOSTA JENSEN
STAGE EIGHT AM RETURNING TO MY
PARENTS WAS NOT AN OPTION. FOR
ME DUE TO THEIR INCARCERATION.
DURING MY TIME AT CLOSER TO
MOVES TO AND MOVED. FROM TWELVE
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS.
UNFORTUNATELY I MOVED FIVE
TIMES BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE WHILE AN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE. THANK YOUNG GAVE
ME A MONTHLY PAYMENT THAT
ARGUMENT HAVE ACTUAL STABLE
HOUSING. AN OVERLY CHALLENGING
HOUSING MARKET. BETWEEN A
GUARDIAN WHO WANTED MORE THAN
THAT FRANK ACT I COULDN'T PAY.
AND BALLOTS VARIANTS WITH A
GUEST WHO'S BEHAVIOR VIOLATED
MY LEASE AND THE TRANSPARENT
WITH THAT I CAN'T STAY WITH
THEM LONG TERM I JUST COULDN'T
SECURE AND STABLE QUITE. I WAS
STARTING FACT STAY IN NEEDED
HELP IDENTIFYING THE STATE
PLACEMENT OPTION THAT WASN'T
GOING TO FALL APART. HOW
NAVIGATION COULD HAVE HELPED ME
WITH THIS WHILE I WAITED FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING TO BECOME
AVAILABLE FOR TWO MONTHS I WAS
HOMELESS. I AM THRILLED MY
SUMMER COURSES AND MIND MENTAL
HEALTH WITH BAD. FORTUNATELY I
DIDN'T GET INTO TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM WHILE IN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. AND AFTER
GETTING THE SYSTEM RIGHT WILL
COPE WITH IT. WHEN I WAS LAID
OFF DUE TO CLOTHING FROM MY
CAMPUS JOB THE PROGRAM WILL BE.
REALLY WEST CORNER THEY WAIVE
MY PORTION OF RENT AND THEY
ALSO HELP ME APPLY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. I'M NOT
GOING TO NEED HELP FOREVER BUT
RIGHT NOW THE ASSISTANCE I
RECEIVED IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
CRUCIAL BRIDGE TO BECOMING
INDEPENDENT. MORE GIVE ME
ACCESS TO THIS BRIDGE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M ACTING FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON. EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET ME NOW ASK- THERE IS NO.
OPPOSITION LISTED ON FILE SO TO
THE MODERATOR FOR COULD OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THEY WISH TO SPEAK
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SHARE
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT EIGHTY FOUR ONE
THREE. PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
TO SHOW SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION
FOR A. B. FOUR ONE THREE. ONLY
DO YOU HAVE ABOUT SIXTEEN IN
THE QUEUE WILL FERRELL LINE A
ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES CANCERS
ON BEHALF OF AT THE AYE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
EIGHT PM PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS WENDY WAY WITH HATHAWAY
SYCAMORES FIRST ALSO SERVICE
PROVIDER AND YOU COORDINATED
ENTRY SYSTEM LEAD AGENCY AND L.
A. COUNTY. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB CORP THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD
PREVENT AND LOWER HOMELESSNESS
AMONG FORMER AND CURRENT FOX IF
YOU. CAN PROVIDE IMPORTANT
HOUSING RESOURCES DURING KEVIN
NINETEEN. AS YOU'VE HEARD THAT
COLLECTED SYSTEM SERVING NEEDS
ARE COMPLEX AND FREQUENTLY
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO INVEST IN HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND CROSS SECTOR
STAFF TRAINING. STAFF ARE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THE FULL
ARRAY OF HOUSING OPTIONS IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTIES SO
THEY CAN BETTER ASSIST YOUNG
PEOPLE OUT THERE EAVING CHAIR
AND OUT THE TRAP TRANSITION. TO
GREATER INDEPENDENCE THANK YOU.
MAXIMO ONE FOR SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DAN AND PHONE WITH
CHILDREN NOW CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR THIRTEEN. MAXIMO
CAROLINA ONE TWENTY NINE
CLEVELAND HAD. I KNOW ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MAXIMO GOODBYE TO ONE OF OUR-
ONE SECOND. ALMOST CAROLINA ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN
ON BEHALF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND IT'S HEALTHY
HOUSING FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC JOHNSON
CALLING FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AS EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTEEN THANK YOU. MAXIMO
TO LINE ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
CALL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JANE SCHROEDER I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST PAGE PER
USE- WHERE ONE OF THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE HOUSING INDEPENDENT
LIVING SERVICES TO YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT ARE AGING OUT OF FOSTER
CARE. AND WE REALLY SEE
FIRSTHAND THE DESPERATE NEED
FOR MORE HAVE THE RESOURCES AND
PROGRAM SUPPORT CHIU CHOI COURT
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE SO THAT THEY
DON'T EXPERIENCE ANYTHING
HOMELESSNESS. AND THESE
PRESSURES HAVE JUST INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY UNDER COGAN
NINETEEN IN OUR PROGRAM ALONE
OVER HALF USED BY THEIR JOBS OR
HAD THEIR WORKING HOURS HI YOU
CAN DEPEND ON NICK WHICH REALLY
MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
TRANSITION OUT OF PROGRAM INTO
STABLE HOUSING. SO WE'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FOURTH FOURTH THIRTEEN
WE THINK IT'LL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE AND ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING GAP FOR YOUNG ADULTS.%
ARE AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO ONE SIX
PER FOUGHT. GET OUT MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH CRUZ I AM A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH CALLING FROM
VENTURA CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD
PREVENT AND REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND PROVIDE CRITICAL
HOUSING SUPPORT RESOURCES
DURING COLD IT. LEAVING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SIX YEARS
AGO I HAVE EXPERIENCED CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS BOOK ON MY OWN AND
WITH ME TO CHILDREN. ONE
FINALLY LEARNING ABOUT PHP PLUS
I HAD TO WAIT SEVERAL MONTHS AT
A TIME FOR A SPOT TO OPEN UP.
LIMITED SPOTS NOT THE TIME I
CAN ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM BUT DIMINISHED AND MY
KIDS AND I WERE MEANT TO COUCH
SURF OR SLEEP IN OUR CAR WHILE
WE WAITED. WHEN I EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS I WOULD FOCUS MORE
ON STRATEGIC GROUNDOUT WHERE WE
WERE GOING TO LIVE AND I HAD TO
SET ALL OF MY OTHER COURT TO
DECIDE. IF WE WERE APRIL IF WE
WERE BETTER ABLE TO HELP YOU
TRANSITION INTO SAFE HOUSING.
YOU COULD BE ABLE TO REDUCE
TRAUMA FOR THEIR CHILDREN
NINETEEN THEIR JOBS AND
CONTINUE PURSUING THEIR
EDUCATION. AB FOUR THIRTEEN
WILL KEEP YOU SAFE HOUSE. AND
ON TRACK WITH THEIR LIVES THANK
YOU. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
BEFORE WE MOVE ON GRASS THE
ONLY SAY OUR NAME. ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE GOING FORWARD
AGAIN. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THANK YOU.
EXCEL MOTEL NINE ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ERICA
NIKKI WITH VOICES AND LEARN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTEEN. MAXIM OF TO LINE ONE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ACTUALL TOMORROW I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS ACTIVO AND WE
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT AB
ONE. AB FOUR THIRTEEN THANK
YOU. MAXIMAL TIELINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LINDA LEE I MARK CASA
I'VE BEEN ACROSS THE FOR TEN
YEARS AND I'M CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH A NINETEEN YEAR OLD I'M
HERE TO EXPRESSED STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU NO MATTER MOTEL NINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MAGGIE EGAN I'M
CALLING WITH REPRESENTING
CONCERT OF LOS ANGELES-
REPRESENTING OVER THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS SERVING AS ADVOCATES
FOR FOSTER YOUTH CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
THIRTEEN. IN FACT ALMOST TELL
NINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE WELL I
HAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JODY GOD I'M REPRESENTING
THE ALL SAINTS EPISCOPAL CHURCH
PASADENA FOSTER CARE PROGRAM WE
WORK EXTENSIVELY WITH FOSTER
YOUTH IN THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES AREA I'M ALSO A FORMER
SUCH APPARENT. AND I'M HERE TO
THE- RIGHT TO EXPRESS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR AB FOUR ONE
THREE PRESS THE LONDON THERE ON
NOW AGAIN ONE THEN FERRELL WELL
NEXT MOVES TO LINE A ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS GENERALLY KEY WITH THE
SPIRIT AT AND WE STRONGLY FAVOR
AB FOUR THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
ENACT SOME OF TIMELINE AT ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHY NO ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS YEAR CORPORATION. FOUR OF
AB FOUR THIRTEEN THANK YOU. AND
I MARIE MINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOUR FOUR B. ONE
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN ONE BEEN. ZERO AND WE DID
NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT THIS TIME WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MASTERCARD ACCOUNTS FOR THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER ROGERS. THANK
YOU- SO IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE
HAVE ACOSTA PROGRAM AND I WAS
ABLE TO SIT DOWN WITH THEM AND
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN
RECOGNIZING IS VERY IMPORTANT
GAP IN THESE KIDS LIVES. AT THE
TIME BETWEEN WHEN THEY GET OUT
OF THE PROGRAM. AND THE NEXT
THREE OR FOUR YEARS IS SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THEM
STAYING OFF THE STREET WHICH IS
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST- INCREASES
IN HOMELESSNESS IS THESE YOUNG
KIDS- SO- I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS AND I APPRECIATE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN BRING THIS
UP. ASK IF THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. I WANT TO THANK A
VETERAN FOR PRESENTING ON MR
TANG'S BEHALF OF WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE NEED A LARGER STRATEGY
TO DEAL WITH HOMELESSNESS IN
GENERAL BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS- THE FACT
IS THE MOST RECENT POINT IN
TIME COUNT IN TWENTY NINETEEN
FOUND OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
HOMELESS YOUTH STATEWIDE- AND
WE THINK THAT'S AN UNDERCOUNT-
AND I THINK THERE IS TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT. IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
FOCUSING ON THIS POPULATION-
BECAUSE OF WHO THEY REPRESENTS
WITH THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT AS
AMENDED ANALYSTS ARE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS- ASK MISERABLE IF YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING REMARKS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT OTHERS MOTION TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
ESERVER- I THINK THIS DIVERSITY
TO MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE AFFORD
I DID NOT MAKE MOTION MIDDLE
MAKE THEM OKAY HE'S MADE A
MOTION IS OUR SECOND. AND WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY. TWO FIVE
TWO I SAY ARE TOO HIGH HI ERICA
HI GABRIEL. CHOLERA ALL RIGHT I.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
CORK SILVA THANKS YOU BYE WEEKS.
ONE FOUR FIVE TWO ZERO SEVEN
MARIE FREEMAN F. R. VOTES TO
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL WAIT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH. RIGHT
AT THIS POINT WITH TWO. OTHER
ITEMS- I THINK WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR. THE GOOD SENATOR
TORONTO TO JOIN US I WILL
PRESENT MY BILL.
RIGHT THIS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU ADA OPEN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- TO OUR COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS A BILL TO
ADDRESS WHAT HAS BEEN AN
ONGOING CYCLE OF INCARCERATION
AND HOMELESSNESS OR PUT ANOTHER
WAY AN ONGOING CYCLE FROM CELL
BLOCKS TO SIDEWALKS AND BACK.
WE KNOW THAT SOLVING A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WILL
REQUIRE ADDRESSING THE PLIGHT
OF FOLKS AS THEY LEAVE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THE
FACT IS. ABOUT 50% OF ALL
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAVE REPORTED A
HISTORY OF INCARCERATION. WHEN
PEOPLE LEAVE OUR PRISONS THEY
NEED A STABLE HOME AND YET CDCR
IS ESTIMATED THAT AT LEAST 20%
OF FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. BECOME HOMELESS
UPON RELEASE AT THIS MOMENT
THERE ARE NO STATE FUNDS TO
HELP THOSE PEOPLE TO BECOME
STABLY HOUSED. FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE TWENTY
SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE HOUSING AND
SECURITY. WE KNOW. THAT ACCESS
TO LONG TERM HOUSING AND LEVEL
WAGES ARE KEYS TO REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AND RECIDIVISM.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE HOMELESS ARE SEVEN TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO RECIDIVIST THAN
SOMEONE WHO IS STABLY HOUSED.
WOULD COVER NINETEEN IMPACT IN
OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS LIVING ON OUR
STREETS. THE NEEDS FOR A
PROGRAM TO HELP REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF DISCHARGES INTO
HOMELESSNESS IS ABSOLUTELY.
CRITICAL IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS OUR STATE PRISON
POPULATION WILL DECLINE TO ITS
LOWEST LEVEL IN THREE DECADES
THIS IS GOING TO RESULT IN TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. BEEN
RELEASED FROM PRISONS AND COULD
RESULT IN OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN COST SAVINGS FOR
CDCR. THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY DOING TWO THINGS
IT WOULD REDIRECT A PORTION OF
CD R. C. SAVINGS. CDCR SAVINGS
TO PROVIDE HOUSING WITH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND IT WOULD SAVE
THE STATE AND TAXPAYERS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING-
FUNDING TO AVOID THE CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION AND HOMELESSNESS-
IN CLOSE WE KNOW THAT
SHEPHERDING PEOPLE FROM CELL
BLOCK THE SIDEWALKS. FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE BOTH THE KEY DRIVER
OF OUR HOMELESS EPIDEMIC IN OUR
DUTY AS A STATE AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
I TIME UNDERSTAND THEIR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
THAT BEING HE NEVER SOLACE FROM
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND ALSO RICHARD
MIRRORLESS. CAN YOU GET THEM ON
THE LINE. I'M ON HERE. GARCIA
GO AHEAD MR MORALIS. IT ANY
CHAIRED ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RICHARD MORALIS. AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE CROP
ORGANIZATION CROP MISSION IS TO
RESTORE LIVES AND NO
COMMUNITIES BY REIMAGINING
REENTRY. I WAS SENTENCED TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO LIFE AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY. AND
INCARCERATED FOR NEARLY TWENTY
ONE YEARS. ALL FOUND SUITABLE
OF MY FIRST HEARING BY THE
BORDER PRISON HEARINGS. EVEN
THOUGH I PAROLED WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. IN POINT
WITH PROP ORGANIZATION. AND
ADVANCED CERTIFICATION AS AN
ALCOHOL AND DRUG COUNSELOR.
AFTER SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING
SIX MONTHS OF TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING. I WAS ON THE BRINK OF
HOMELESSNESS. THE TYPICAL
TRANSITIONING HOUSING SOLUTION.
OUR HAVE PRISON LIKE
RESTRICTIONS AND ARE FILLED
WITH CONDITIONS THAT BARELY
MEET BASIC NEEDS I VISITED OVER
TWENTY APARTMENT COMPLEXES IN
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA.
AND FOUND IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO FIND HOUSING. EVERY ONE OF
THEM ASKED ME A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS THAT SHUT DOWN MY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOUSING THEY
WOULD HAVE DO YOU HAVE TO
YEAR'S A RENTAL HISTORY THE
ANSWER WAS NO. DO YOU HAVE A
YEAR OF VERIFIED EMPLOYMENT THE
ANSWER WAS NO DO YOU HAVE A SIX
FORTY CREDIT SCORE ABOVE MY
ANSWER WAS NO ARE YOU CONVICTED
OF A FELONY ANSWER WAS YES.
EVERYONE SAID THAT I MAY AS
WELL NOT EVEN FILL OUT AN
APPLICATION BECAUSE I WOULD
MOST CERTAINLY BE DENIED. HAD
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE CROP
ORGANIZATION NOT COSIGN FOR AN
APARTMENT. I WOULD HAVE BEEN
LIVING OUT OF MY CAR. I HAD MY
GRANDFATHER NOT COSIGN FOR MY
CAR. I WOULD HAVE BEEN HOME. I
CAN SPEAK THE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF ALL THOSE THAT I
WAS IN TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
WITH. ONLY ONE HAS STABLE
HOUSING TODAY THE REST
SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME HOMELESS.
AFTER THEIR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING TERM ENDED AND NOW
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION. I
CAN'T IMAGINE THRIVING
PERSONALLY OR PROFESSIONALLY
WITHOUT STABLE HOUSING. THE
FIVE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
DIRECTORS AT THE CROP
ORGANIZATION ARE HELPING OTHERS
NAVIGATE THIS ISSUE WITH THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING SHORT AND
LONG TERM HOUSING SOLUTIONS FOR
RETURNING COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
MANY ARE CRAWLING WITH THE BEST
OF INTENTIONS BUT THE BARRIERS
TO HOUSING AND THE SUBSEQUENT.
INCREASED RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
EXACT EXACERBATED LACK OF
EMPLOYMENT WHICH ULTIMATELY
RESULTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
PROBLEMS WITH RECIDIVISM.
INSTEAD OF INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS WE BELIEVE THE
PUBLIC WOULD PREFER LEGITIMATE
HOUSING SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO PASSED AWAY
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT AND SELF
SUFFICIENCY. BECAUSE OF THIS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT AND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CAN
WE CONNECT THE WITNESS NUMBER
TWO MISTER SOLACE. THANKS BYE
CRIVELLA TEXTURE SHE DROPPED
OFF OF THE CALL I'M NOT SURE IF
THEY DIAL BACK IN BUT IF YOU
ARE ON THE CALL AS THE PURCHASE
A PAINT YOU CAN PRESS STAR THEN
ZERO. TO GET AN OPERATOR.
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT. IS THERE
ANY ACTIVITY. I DO NOT SHALL-
THAT CRISTINA RESULTS HAS
REJOINED OKAY WHY DON'T WE GO
ON IN AND- IF YOU WANT TO OPEN
UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TEST ME
TESTIMONY DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
FOLKS OUT THERE. SHARE LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
EIGHTY THREE TWO EIGHT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
EIGHTY. THREE TWO EIGHT PRESS
THE ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW AS A
REMINDER OR ACTING THAT YOU
ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION HOWEVER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE EIGHTY THREE
TWO EIGHT. ONLY DO YOU HAVE
ABOUT FIVE IN THE QUEUE WILL
START WITH LINE ONE TWENTY TWO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CENTERS ON
BEHALF OF THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. MAXIMAL TO LINE
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GLAD.
THE SHERIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WE ARE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB THREE TWENTY
NINE IN STRONG SUPPORT. MAXIMAL
CAROLINE AT ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE BY HAD. HI JOHN I'M
CALLING YOU FOR- CENTER I
NEEDED ANOTHER NUMBER. SHE. WE
ARE READY HAVE- AB FOR ONE THE
TIME SECTION AT OKAY THEN I
CALLED IN TO LET. NOT CAROLINE
ONE FORTY PLEASE CALL. MISTER
CHAIRMAN RAND MARC ON BEHALF TO
HELP CARE FOR AND HEALTHY HOW
DOWN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THAT
MOTEL LINE ONE YOU THOUGHT I
HAD. HI PACK FROM THE ACLU OF
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY. AND THAT CAROLINE ONE
FIFTY PLEASE CALL. HI MY GETS
WITH LEGAL SERVE FOR WITH
CHILDREN CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
A THREE EIGHT AND PROVIDE MORE
SIR FOR REENTRY THANK. MAX
SILVA LINE ONE THING TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVEN HELPING TELL
COASTLINE IN THE TRUNK OF A
THREE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW THE- AS. FOR EIGHTY THREE
EIGHT PRESS OE THEN ARE NOW A
ALLOW FERAL. WE HAVE ONE IN THE
LOCAL TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT WE'VE
GOT. OKAY NOW LOOKS LIKE WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION DID YOU WANT TO OPEN
UP THE LINE FOR ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU OPPOSED THAT
AB THREE TWO EIGHT PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ON NOW AGAIN. ONE
DAY IN VERO TO OPPOSE H. B.
YEAR. THREE TWO EIGHT. AT THAT
TIME NO ONE TO MAKE YOU. GREAT
THEN AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO CLOSE THAT AND I'D LIKETO
BRING IT BACK- TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS GOVERNESSES BRICK
SILVA ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU. IS
THIS ON. YEAH THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR BRINGING
AB THREE TWENTY EIGHT FORWARD
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT I FULLY
SUPPORT I IF WE LOOK AT. THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED AND
COMING OUT AND AS YOU SAID FROM
CELLS TO SIDEWALK- THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING. WE
CERTAINLY HAD AN ISSUE BEFORE
COVERED WE HAVE EVEN MORE OF AN
ISSUE FOR ALL OF OUR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE FACING
HOMELESSNESS. BUT IF YOU
IMAGINE SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN
INCARCERATED AND THE DEBT THAT
IS STACKED AGAINST THEM THEY
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES GETTING OUT.
AFTER THEY HAVE SERVED THEIR
TIME. AND ALL TOO OFTEN WE SEE
THE PATTERN REPEAT AND REPEAT
AND REPEAT. ONE OF THE PROJECTS
THAT IS OUT THERE THAT IS
HIGHLY ACCLAIMED. IS A PROJECT
CALLED PROJECT REBOUND IN THIS
IS HOSTED AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON. AND OTHER CSU'S BUT
IT'S SIMPLY A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PERSON WHO IS
INTERESTED IN GOING TO COLLEGE
OR ALREADY HAS SOME COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE. CAN MOVE INTO
FULLER TEN IRWIN HOUSE AND SO
IF YOU GET OUT OF. PRISON OR
BEEN INCARCERATED YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REAP FOR HOUSING.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE'S HOPE
AND FOR THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING AT THIS HOME. MANY OF
MANY OF THEM ARE GRADUATING NOT
ONLY WITH THE FOUR YEAR DEGREE
BUT WITH MASTERS AND IN TURN
GOING BACK TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHAT
HOUSING CAN DO. NOT ONLY FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED BUT FOR
ANYONE TO HAVE A PLACE TO LAY
YOUR HEAD A PLACE TO CALL HOME.
SO I NOT ONLY SUPPORT THIS BUT
BELIEVE THIS REALLY IS THE KEY.
BUT IT'S ALSO THE KEY FOR
TAXPAYERS WE ALL TO OFTEN ARE
GOING TO PAY SOME WAY OR
ANOTHER WE'RE PAYING WHILE
THEY'RE IN PRISON WE PAY WHEN
THEY GO TO THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND WE PAY A LOT IN MANY WAYS
WHEN MANY TIMES THEY RETURN TO
BEHAVIORS THAT CAN ASSAULTER
COMMUNITIES. SO I'M ABOUT
LOOKING TOWARDS OPTIMISM AND
HOPE AND LOOKING AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN REIMAGINE. FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE ASCENDED HOW CAN THEY COME
BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
BECOME THE RESPONSIBLE ADULTS
THAT WE WANT THEM TO BE. I
FULLY SUPPORT AB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT AND MOVE THIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. SECOND
IF IT WASN'T SECOND ON THAT-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR CHIU OF
FOR BRING THIS BILL FOR A PROUD
JOY AUTHOR AND I THINK- MY
COLLEAGUES TO SPOKE VERY WELL
AS TO WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY I REALLY LIKE THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF TOOLS AVAILABLE IN TERMS OF
INCENTIVIZING- OF LANDLORDS IN
AND NUMBER TWO. BE INVOLVED THE
PROGRAMS WAS NOT JUST A MATTER
OF THE RESOURCES BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO WANT TO BE A
PARTNERSHIP- AND THE
RECOGNITION THAT ULTIMATELY-
OVER THE YEARS AS WE CORRECTLY-
COMMITTEE TAKEN REALLY SERIOUS
STEPS IN TERMS OF THE CAR
SERRATION RECOGNIZING. THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO-
REALLY TURN. BACK THE TIDE OVER
MANY YEARS. OF HEFTY SENTENCING
AT A GREAT COST YOU IN COSTS AS
WELL AS FISCAL COSTS. THAT
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH WE ALSO HAVE
TO PUT OUR INVESTMENT IN A
THOUGHTFULNESS INTO WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE GETS
RELEASED AND- WELL THAT'S WHAT
I WAS VERY. HAPPY TO- JOINED UP
WITH THIS BILL AND REALLY GREAT
FOR THE AUTHOR OUR CHAIR- FOR
ESTABLISHING THIS PROGRAM THAT
I THINK AND REALLY DO HOPE-
WILL BECOME A MODEL. FOR HOW
YOU REALLY DEAL WITH THE-
GLOBAL ISSUES THAT SOMEONE HAS
WHEN THEY GET RELEASED TO MAKE
SURE FIRST AND FOREMOST. THAT
THEY HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD- BECAUSE ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES CAN BE RESOLVED IF THEY
DON'T HAVE. A STABLE PLACE TO
LIVE AND WE'VE CERTAINLY SEEN
THAT- DURING THE COVERAGE
CRISIS AS FOLKS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED THAT. THEIR ISSUES
DON'T END WITH THEM GETTING
RELEASED FROM THE STATE OF
INCARCERATION IN MANY WAYS-
THEIR ISSUES ARE JUST BEGINNING
OF THE END AND THE DOMINO
EFFECT. ALL STARS WITH HOUSING
SO OF A VERY HAPPY. SUPPORT
AGAIN WANT TO THANK ARCHER.
ANYONE ELSE. L. CLOSE AND SO
THIS IS A THIS ISSUE WITH REESE
RECIDIVISM IS REALLY M. S. IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT ISN'T
ALWAYS JUST ABOUT THE HOUSING
THAT'S WHAT ONE OF MY CONCERNS
IS THE BILL AS THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY BEING PUT INTO THE
HOUSING COMPONENT WHEN THERE
ARE TWO EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT
OTHER COMPONENTS AND THAT'S
ADDICTION AND JOB TRAINING AND
AS MR MERRILEES HAD SAID SO
ELOQUENTLY ON IT WHEN HE WAS
SPEAKING TO WITNESS- EIGHTY HE
HAD. A LOT OF THE TOOLS YOU
NEED TO GET A JOB BUT HE DIDN'T
HAVE THAT TYPE LINE TO GET THE
JOB BECAUSE THAT JOB IS WHAT
ULTIMATELY PAYS FOR THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND NOT ONLY GETTING
HOUSING BY KEEPING HOUSING AND
WHILE I THINK THIS HOUSING
ELEMENT OF IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
IT'S ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IT SEEMS TO BE BEING
JUST SPENT TOWARDS THE HOUSING
BUT NOT TOWARDS THE ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND THE JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHETHER THAT BE
TECHNICAL EDUCATION OR DEGREE
PROGRAMS. AND THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE ARE UNDER SERVED IN OUR
PRISONS AS AS I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE ABOUT
WHY WHY ARE WE NOT SUCCESSFUL
IN THAT WHY ARE WE NOT
EDUCATING MORE PEOPLE WHY ARE
WE NOT GETTING THEM READY TO
COME OUTSIDE AND BE SUCCESSFUL
SO THAT THAT'S MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
NINE AGENCIES THAT DO FORTY ONE
PROGRAMS. TO HELP HOMELESSNESS-
OUR HELP WITH THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM AND WE'RE JUST NOT
SUCCESSFUL AND WE SPEND. THREE
BILLION DOLLARS AND WE'RE GOING
TO SPEND MORE. BUT SOMEHOW
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO CONSOLIDATE
THESE. INTO SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
AND HAVE THEM BE MORE
COORDINATED- SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME OF MY CONCERNS WITH IT-
THAT TO ADD AT THIS TIME- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY COURT MISTER
MARK SILVA. IN A SECOND BY
MISTER KALRA. SO THE SECRETARY
WANNA CALL THE ROLL OUR DID YOU
WANT TO CLOSE I'M SORRY I'D
LOVE TO CLIENTS AND- VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS- PRETTY
GOOD FOR COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I WANT TO SAY TO
THE VICE CHAIR. I'M NOT SURE IF
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT
THIS MONEY WOULD BE USED FOR
BUT- THIS MONEY WOULD VERY MUCH
GO TO A SUPPORT OF HOUSING
MODEL. THAT ADDRESSES JOB
TRAINING THAT ADDRESSES
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IN FACT IN THE
BILL IT SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT
SERVICES MUST BE PROVIDED TO
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR HOME. THAT
INCLUDE- AND I'LL JUST STAY
HERE LINKAGES TO EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES. AS WELL AS
LINKAGES TO- MEDICAL FUNDED
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT AND MEDICAL TREATMENT
WE KNOW. THAT THE BEST WAY TO
GET THESE FOLKS UP ON THEIR
FEET. AND GET THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IS TO PUT A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS BUT ALSO
PROVIDE THEM ACCESS. TO THE
VERY SERVICES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE NOT
JUST TALKING ABOUT. PUTTING A
ROOF OVER SOMEONE'S HEAD WERE
PARKING ABOUT FULLY
INTEGRATING- THE SERVICES AND
WE KNOW IF WE DO THAT. YOU KNOW
AT THE MOMENT- CDCR SPENDING
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO INCARCERATE
SOMEONE IN A PRISON CELL. IF WE
PUSH THEM OUT ONTO THE STREETS
THAT COSTS OUR TAXPAYERS ABOUT
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. IF WE PUT. FOLKS IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WITH SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. COUPLED WITH THE
SERVICES THAT WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT. IT'S ONLY GONNA COST US
ABOUT AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR AND I
WOULD ALSO SAY GIVEN THAT. HALF
OF ALL FOLKS ON OUR STREETS
HAVE AN EXPERIENCE. WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IF WE
ARE ABLE TO HOUSES INDIVIDUALS.
WITH A CHANCE AT- CUTTING. THAT
NUMBER POTENTIALLY IN HALF SO
THAT'S- REALLY THE VISION OF
THIS BILL. HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS IF
THERE'S A WAY TO- TO MAKE IT
EVEN CLEARER FOR YOU WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT BUT- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHTS RESERVED YES I DID
READ THROUGH THE BILL AND- AND
THOSE THINGS ARE CLEAR TO ME I
JUST. I'M LOOKING AT PROGRAMS
THAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE FACT
BEFORE THEY GET OUT AND HAVING
THOSE PROGRAMS TO BE SUCCESSFUL
SO THAT WHEN THEY GET OUT- THEY
ARE READY FOR THAT PART OF IT
AND THAT. THAT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PART IS CRITICAL BUT
THERE'S ALSO A POINT- ARE A
PART OF THIS. WHERE THERE. WELL
THEY'RE NOT- REQUIRED THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO HAVE SOBRIETY
AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS
HOUSING AND THEY'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO MAKE YOU KNOW DID
TO BE DRUG FREE AND THOSE ARE
THE TRAPS TO PEOPLE ARE FALLING
INTO BECAUSE THEY GO FROM DON'T
GO JUST GO FROM PRISON TO THE
STREET THEY GO FROM STREET. TO
PRESENT AN INTERACTIVE STREET
AGAIN AND THEN BACK TO PRISON
AND THAT'S THE END AND ALL OF
THOSE ARE THE UNKNOWN DAY IF
THE ADDICTION PART OF THAT IS A
HUGE PART OF THAT AND SO THAT'S
MY CONCERN AND I UNDERSTAND.
AND IF THIS WERE- IF NOT ALL OF
THE MONEY WAS BEING- RESERVED
FOR THE HOUSING PART BUT HAS
HAD MORE DIVERSE TO SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED. THAT'S WHEN
YOU'RE GONNA BREAK THEIR
ADDICTION AND THAT'S WHAT MY
CONCERN IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE SPENDING SOME MONEY ON
THAT PART OF IT. SO I
APPRECIATE THE BILL IT'S IN A
YEAH I REALLY DO- TODAY I JUST
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS. THANK YOU
ON GOING CONVERSATION AND THIS
TIME ABOUT MISS SECRETARY CAN
CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY EIGHT.
GOOD PASSAGE. THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO FIVE TWO
FIVE THEY ARE DON'T KNOW YOU
KNOW GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA
RIGHT FOLLOW I HIGHLY. HIGHLY
NO MAIENSCHEIN CLARK SILVA OKAY
SILVA I WICKS FIVE WEEKS. FIVE
FIVE TWO THANK YOU HAVE
MENTIONED OF PASSES TO THE
ASSEMBLY FIVE TWO. COOL. YEAH.
MISTER MISTER KELLY KELLY THE
CHANGE ON THE HOUSE RULES AT
HIGHS NOT BUT- WITH THAT ARE WE
HAVE ONE FINAL BILL FOR TODAY I
THINK IT IS FILE ITEM. FOR FROM
NOT MISTAKEN. PHYLUM SIX SB
FIFTY ONE SENATOR THEY'RE ALSO.
OKAY PLEASE OKAY WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- GOOD TO SEE
YOU UP MEMBERS- OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SB FIFTY ONE. WHICH WILL
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL COST SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE IT WILLPRODUCE A
MODEL TO EXPAND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND IS GOING TO ENHANCE
OF HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITY
AND THIS BILL ALIGNS WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS TO FOSTER HOUSING
INNOVATION ON. EXCESS STATE
LAND FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DISPLACED
FAMILIES WHO LIVED IN WHAT IS
CALLED THE SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR
IN ORDER TO BUILD A FREEWAY
THROUGH THE COMMUNITIES OF EL
SERENO IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND THE CITIES OF
PASADENA AND SOUTH PASADENA. IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY OUR
LEGISLATURE DECLARED NO FREEWAY
WOULD BE BUILT. WE INTRODUCED
SB FIFTY WANT TO IMPLEMENT A
FAIR PROCESS FOR TENANTS TO BUY
THEIR HOMES. AND BRING MORE
LONG TERM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INTO EL SERENO. MANY PROPERTIES
HAVE BEEN SITTING VACANT AND IN
DISREPAIR FOR YEARS IN THE
MIDST OF THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
THE BILL WOULD GIVE CURRENT
TENANTS THE FIRST RIGHT TO
PURCHASE THEIR HOME AND IF THEY
ARE NOT INTERESTED OR NOT ABLE
TO BUY THE HOME IT REQUIRES
THAT A PRO A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
HOUSING RELATED ENTITY. WHO
PURCHASES THE PROPERTY PROVIDED
FOR LOW AND INCOME LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME. RENTAL OR
OWNERSHIP HOUSING FOR AT LEAST
FIFTY FIVE YEARS GIVING THE
FIRST RIGHT OF OCCUPANCY TO THE
PRESENT OCCUPANTS THESE HOUSING
RELATED ENTITIES COULD BE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR NONPROFIT
HOUSING ENTITIES. SB FIFTY ONE
ALLOWS THESE ENTITIES TO BY THE
PROPERTIES AT THE ORIGINAL
PRICE. IN EXCHANGE FOR
REMODELING PRESERVING
AFFORDABILITY AND MAINTAINING
THEM. VACANT PROPERTIES ALSO
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY FOR HOUSING RELATED
ENTITY TO CONVERT TO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING UNDER
THE FIFTY FIVE YEAR AFFORDABLE
RENTAL COVENANT. THE CURRENT
LAW IS FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND IS NOW OVER
THIRTY YEARS OLD IT SETS THE
ORDER OF SALES BUT DOES NOT
CREATE LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING. CURRENT LAW WAS
WRITTEN TO FACILITATE HOUSING
TO EXISTING GOOD STANDING
TENANTS IF THE VACANT
PROPERTIES WERE TO GO THROUGH
THE EXISTING PROCESS THEY WOULD
BE AUCTIONED OFF AND ULTIMATELY
OPENED UP TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER. THAT'S A RECIPE FOR
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
THIS BILL WAS DEVELOPED AFTER
HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF
CONVERSATIONS AND MEETINGS WITH
RESIDENTS ADVOCATES TENANTS OF
CALTRANS PROPERTIES CALTRANS
OFFICIALS LA CITY AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS. SB FIFTY ONE
PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND EXPANSION OF
AFFORDABLE RENTALS. THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT IN THIS BILL PROVIDE THE
BENEFIT OF ENHANCING
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS IN OUR STATE- I
SEE. MY COLLEAGUE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARILLO WHO IS THE
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR AND- TO ADD
TO THIS PRESENTATION I'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO AND- NOT
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE TO SEE TO
THE WITNESS TABLE IF EITHER
SOME SAY THAT SHE COULD TESTIFY
EITHER. FROM THE BACK. PERFECT
UNLESS YOU WANNA DO YOU WANNA
COME UP TO YOU WANNA COME TO
THE REST. COME ON UP. GOOD TECH
TEAM HERE. NUMBER THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S ALWAYS A
GREAT WAY TO HAVE A GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR
STATE SENATOR TO BE ABLE TO
WORK ON ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPACTFUL AND IMPORTANT TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND I WANT TO THANK
CENTER THE DOCILE FOR LEADING
ON SB FIFTY ONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR DOING THIS HEARING TO
HEAR SB FIFTY ONE TODAY FOR
YEARS. AFTER A FEW YEARS NOW
CENTER THAT ALSO AND I HAVE
ENGAGE WITH RESIDENTS RENTING
APARTMENTS AND HOMES FROM
CALTRANS IN OUR COMMUNITY WE
HAVE URGE FAIR TREATMENT OF
THESE TENANTS AND THE EXPEDITED
SALE OF THESE PROPERTIES AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RATES
SEVENTY YEARS AGO THROUGH
EMINENT DOMAIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEGAN DISPLACING
FAMILIES. AND ALTERING THE
COMMUNITY OF EL SERENO FOR A
FREEWAY EXPANSION CALTRANS
BROUGHT PROPERTIES WITHOUT
REGARD FOR THE FAMILIES IN THE
CORRIDOR DISRUPTING THE
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
FABRIC OF THIS PREDOMINATELY
LATINO COMMUNITY AS THE FUTURE
OF THE SEVEN TEN FREEWAY
HUSBAND DECIDED EL SERENO HAS
BEEN ACUTELY IMPACTED BY
NEGLECT TRAFFIC CONGESTION. AND
VACANCY WITH NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
CURRENTLY VACANT NEARLY HALF
THE CALDERON HOMES IN EL SERENO
AND MANY IN POOR CONDITION WE
HAVE AN URGENT OPPORTUNITY TO
REPAIR AND IMPROVE THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD. WE WANT TO REPAIR
THESE HOMES AND MAKE THEM
RESPECTFUL DIGNIFIED LIVING
SPACES WHILE EXPANDING LONG
TERM AFFORDABILITY THIS BILL
HELPS ACHIEVE THAT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IS A TOP PRIORITY
FOR US THIS YEAR IT HAS BEEN
FOR MANY YEARS AND EVERY YEAR
UNTIL THIS CRISIS HAS ENDED IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE PURSUE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE
AND EXPAND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS. ARE BILL SIX TO MOVE
OWNERSHIP AWAY FROM CALTRANS
SECURE LONG TERM AFFORDABILITY
AND THE NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS WHILE ENSURING CURRENT
CALTRAIN TENANTS ARE PROTECTED
BY RULES ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RESIDENTS RENTING APARTMENTS
AND HOMES IN THE SEVENTEEN
CORRIDOR DESERVE FAIR TREATMENT
AND STABLE HOUSING. SB FIFTY
ONE PROVIDE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION FOR HEALING FOCUS ON
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF EXPANDING
AND PRESERVING. AFFORDABILITY
FOR ALL THESE PROPERTIES WHILE
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
TENANTS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL THIS IS THE BILL AS VERY.
CLOSE TO THE SENATOR NINE IS
IT'S IN OUR COMMUNITY IN OUR
DISTRICT I WENT TO EL SERENO
MIDDLE SCHOOL RIGHT IN THIS
COMMUNITY. AND I KNOW VERY WELL
WITH WHAT THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS OF THESE HOMES ARE
BECAUSE I LIVE THERE. I DRIVE
AROUND I SEE THEM CALTRANS HAS
NOT BEEN. A GOOD LANDLORD FOR
MANY YEARS A LOT OF THESE HOMES
NEED MASSIVE REPAIR AND WE NEED
TO GET THAT WORK DONE NOW. AND
ENSURE THAT IT MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN EYEFUL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WHEN WE IT'S BEEN
EMOTIONAL THE BILL THERE'S A
SECOND LET US MOVE TO OUR MAIN
WITNESSES ON THE TELEPHONE- TO
THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR JENNY
SCANLON THE CHIEF DEVELOPMENT
OFFICER FOR THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS TINA BELIEVES THAT I'M
COST FIFTY NEEDS GAMBLING WE'RE
WITH THE HOUSING AUTHORITY OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND WE
GENERALLY SUPPORT THE PASSING
OF SB FIFTY ONE AND IT'S
EXPEDIENT RENDITION FOR THE USE
OF THESE PROPERTIES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
RENTAL IN THE EL SERENO AREA.
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
DURING EARLY COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AROUND THESE
PROPERTIES HAVE BEEN THAT THE
COMMUNITY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THESE PROPERTIES AND THAT THE
REPAIR WORK IN MANAGEMENT AND
MISS BILL ALLOWS FOR THAT. OUR
MISSION AT THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY IS TO CREATE AND
PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
WE SEE THIS BILL AS A NECESSITY
AND MUCH NEEDED FOR THE EL
SERENO AREA WHERE THERE'S A
LARGE HOMELESS POPULATION WHO
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE QUICK
TRANSITION OF THESE PROPERTY.
WHAT THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS IS ONGOING WE AT THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY SEAT SB FIFTY
ONE OF A LARGE HOUSING SOLUTION
OR. THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH I KNOW THE
THERE IS ENOUGH WITNESS ON LINE
WHO AVAILABLE TO QUESTIONS-
KAREN LANDERS. THE GENERAL
COUNSEL TO THE SAN DIEGO
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT SYSTEM.
HELLO SIR ANY OTHER COMMENTS-
TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE. WE DO
NOT HAVE A ANY OPPOSITION OF
FILE OPEN UP THE LINES TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY WISH
TO SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND FINING COMPANIES PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ONE
FORTY FIVE YEAR- LINE IS OPEN
AND IF I COULD JUST NOTICED
YOU'RE A MEMBER YOU COULD BRING
TO SMARTEN UP WE HAVE THE COULD
PLEASE JUST TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I WILL MISTER CHAIR RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. I AM
VERY GOOD I'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
FOR THE NEXT NUMBER TO POPULATE
THE NEXT PERSON.
THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE LINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
TAKE YOUR NAME. HI MY NAME IS
ANDREA LOPEZ AND I'M OUT DURING
A RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT THE FIFTY ONE
IMPROVING HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
MAINTAINING THE NEIGHBORHOOD
BILL OF OUR COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PARGETER LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO ONE MOMENT OPEN
AIRLINE. LADY PANTHERS ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. TEN BACKSLIDE ONE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
LINES OPEN. WITH NO RESPONSIBLE
GUN TO LINE- ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME NOT
TO BE THAT CARRERA. ARE THOSE
DETAILS SAID IN A COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST PLACE OPPOSE THIS
BILL IS VERY DISCRIMINATORY TO
THE RESIDENCE ALSO DENTAL
ESPECIALLY THE CALTRANS
ISLANDS. THERE'S BEEN A SEVERE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY THE
PASSING OF THIS BILL POLLACK
COMMITTEE OPPORTUNITY HAVE
REFUSED TO LISTEN OVERWHELMING
OPPOSITION TO SB. FIFTY ONE BY
CALTRANS TENANTS. LOTS OF
ORIGINALLY DESCRIBED AN TAX.
TOWARD THE COAST SO IT'S
CONSISTENT SUCCESS MAKES HIM
BECAUSE HE'S A SERVANT SIR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE TO STATE- WE
HAVE GATHERED THAT YOU OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL AND- WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE'LL NOW GO TO THE
NEXT WEEK OR- HEY GOOD LINE ONE
THIRTY HERE LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS A LEFT HANDED DOWN
THIS BILL AND I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ALSO HEAR THE
VOICES OF THE CALTECH PANNING-
THEY HAVE NOT VERY MUCH JUDY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FANTAIL. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE ARE
ASKING FOLKS TO PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF WITH A NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SUPPORTER POSSIBILE WHEN WE
GO TO THE NEXT BIG HALF. THANK
YOU LINE ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE FIVE ZERO. HI
MY NAME IS THAT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN A LONG TIME RESIDENT OUT
THERE YOU KNOW AND IF DRUNK THE
PARK AT THE FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
ONE SEVEN ZERO IS OPEN ONE
SEVEN ZERO. HELLO THIS IS- TIM
IVERSON I'M LOOKING AT IT
CALTRANS TENANTS IN THE SEVEN
TEN CORRIDOR AND I OPPOSE THIS
DISRESPECTFUL AND NON DIGNIFIED
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOUNG
SPEAKER. NEXT AVAILABLE
CAROLINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY MOBILE MONEY TO
FLORIDA RESIDENT OF INTERNAL OR
YOU'RE IN THE CUP HOLDER. THANK
YOU THE EMAIL COMPANY YOUR MEAL
FONG WORE CLINTON. BORDER
THOUGHT- THIS A LOT OR THE
PROGRAM GREAT THERE IS IN A LOT.
MAXO ALLTEL NINE ONE SIX ONE
CALL. NOON MY NAME IS MARGARET
ARAMBULA NAMAN BEING ARRESTED
IN A FORTY SEVEN YEAR AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIFTY ONE
THANK YOU. NEXT ALMOST TO LINE
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALL
THE LOPEZ FOR FULL DISCLOSURE
I'M ALSO PRESIDENT REPORT WHILE
THE COMMISSION FASCICULUS
TRACKLIST CONQUERING AND
ETCETERA LEADER IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BECAUSE IF YOU WANT. TO
BRING EQUITY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
MAX CAROLINE SEVEN PLEASE CALL
I HAD. MY NAME IS DORIS LOOK
HOW I'M A TWENTY YEAR EL CAMINO
RESIDENTS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIFTY ONE. IN MAXIMO
CAROLINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY SON SHINE AND THEN
I'M A LONGTIME RESIDENT AND-
WHAT UNITED CALTRANS TENANTS
AND AYE OPPOSED SB FIFTY ONE-
IT DOES NOT- SUPPORT THE
CALTRAIN PENDING BUT ALL. I
KNEW STRONG OPPOSITION OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WEEK
NEXT ALMOST. MAXIMO FIFTH NINE
PEOPLE. HI MY NAME IS LISA
MARIE CO AND I AND THE REST
ABOUT THREE NOW AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FIFTY ONE.
MAXIMO TIELINE ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
OF MY BOOK A LITTLE I'M A
RESIDENT OF INCIDENTAL AND
EISENMANN ALLY FOR UNITED
CALTRANS TENANTS THIS BILL-
STRONG OPPOSITION TO IT IT
DOESN'T REPRESENT US RESIDENTS
ARE CALTRANS SENATE. MAXIMO
CAROLINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MONICA
MARTINEZ LOPEZ I'M IN ALTOONA
RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT THE FIFTY ONE IMPROVING HOME
OWNERSHIP. AND MAINTAINING THE
NEIGHBORHOOD FEEL OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND MAXIMO CAROLINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE
MALDONADO AND I AM STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. FIFTY ONE.
NEXT THE MOTEL NINE ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I KNOW
ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. L. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AT LEAST FIVE ONE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE- NOW AGAIN ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE ONE. NOW
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
MORE IN THE QUEUE LOCAL TO LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS BILL WOULD. BE
EIGHTY EIGHT FORMER CALCUTTA
AND THAT WAS THE BIG THAT MIGHT
LEGAL RENT POLICY AND REYES RAN
10% EVERY SIX MONTHS. THE
CURRENT CALTRANS CAN IDENTICAL
ARMOR VICE PRESIDENT OIL
CHEMICAL AND ATOMIC WORKERS ONE
DASH EIGHT NINE FIVE THE
PROBLEM NUMBER OF. THE
ORGANIZING COMMITTEE DIRECTED
YOUR LONG STRIKE OF. BAKER
STRAWBERRY PICKERS AND KNOCKED.
AS A REMINDER YOUR- YOU STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE I'VE ACTUALLY
BE FIVE ONE. GLOBAL TEL NINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ANGELA FLORES I'M A
UCT PANIC IN SOUTH PASADENA AND
I AM A STAKEHOLDER ON THE NOW
DEFUNCT SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR AND
THAT AND ALL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. DEDUCTIBLES BILL SB
FIFTY ONE. AND ACCESSIBLE
MULTILINE ONE NINETEEN PEOPLE I
HAD. MY NAME IS CAROLINE ROMERO
I AM BEEN A CHEMICAL FORTY
YEARS. AND I AM FOR SB. FIFTY
ONE. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PEOPLE HAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROBIN LOPEZ I'M INDULGING A
RESIDENT AND IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY ONE. AND AT THIS TIME WE
SHOW NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET US
BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
ZEROCHAN WITH THE BILL FOR.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION REVIVED HIS
QUICK SERVICE- SECOND SECOND
I'M IS WICKS AND- I WANT TO SAY
TO THE AUTHOR APPRECIATE TO
HEAR ADVOCACY ALONG WITH YOUR
PENCIL CO AUTHOR ON THIS- I
KNOW I SUPPORTED AND I BELIEVE-
IT GOT OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR EIGHT ZERO- BECAUSE
IMPORTS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION FORWARD AND MAKING
SURE THAT THAT WE ARE
STABILIZING THE HOUSING
SITUATION. AND THAT WITH THAT
HAVE THE SUPPORT AGAIN TODAY
LESSER ANY OTHER COMMENTS-
UNLESS GIVEN THE FINAL CLOSING
WORDS YES I'M- VERY PROUD THE
REASON THIS BILL I THINK IS SO
GOOD IS BECAUSE OF MY
PARTNERSHIP WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AFFECT REAL I WANT TO
THANK ALL. OF YOU VERY MUCH IN
OUR COMMUNITY. VIRGIN ISLANDS
SUPER. WITH THAT MADAMS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AS FIFTY ONE-
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS. ARE
TWO FIVE TWO FIVE THEY ARE TOO
HIGH YEAH HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL
LIFE KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
HIGHLY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NINE PORK SILVA.
OKAY SILVA I. WICKS I. EIGHT
TWO ZERO THREE TWO YOUR ITEMS
OUT AGAIN. LET'S SERVE THIS
MOMENT LET'S DO PATTERNS GO
BACK THROUGH THE FILE STARTING
FILE ITEM ONE FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY MATE- WE HAVE
THE ADOPTION OF COMMUTER RULES
LET'S GO BACK TO THE ADOPTION
YES ABDUCTION COMMITTEE RULES
ALL THE UP SOME NUMBERS.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. NOW
TO SEE YOU THANK YOU OKAY NOW
TO OTHER BILLS AND VOTER FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH IS MY ADAM ABC
TWENTY EIGHT- IT'S FIVE TO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. GO
TO OUT OUR FILE ITEM THREE AB
FOUR ONE ONE IRWIN- AB FOUR
ELEVEN- ERR WHEN GABRIELLE. HI
APRIL I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I. EIGHT TWO ZERO THE BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM FOR HE BEFORE
THIRTEEN TEN. GABRIELLE HI
APRIL I. MAIENSCHEIN THANKS.
NINE FIVE WEEKS FIVE WEEKS BY.
EVERYONE ON BOARD FOR FILE ITEM
SIX LET'S NOT GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH IS FILE ITEM TO
EIGHTY THREE FOUR FIVE FOLLOW
IN FIVE D. B. FOUR KEY TO.
CALLING UP SOME NUMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN HI. WE ARE. EIGHT
TWO ZERO MADAM SECRETARY THE
COMPUTER BUSINESS FOR THE DAY
YES ALEXANDER MUCH.